improvements are coming to the historic  West Side today officials gather to  break ground on the Jackson Avenue  street project it will whiten Street  sidewalks add street lights trees new  water lines and even replacement of the  pavement the changes will be along  Jackson Avenue and Owens City officials  say they hope to continue the growth of  the area and helping community members  and businesses in the area  we're going to continue to advance our  community whatever that takes if it's 5  years 10 years 20 years 30 years 50  years we're going to be here  well until the project is completed  Jackson Avenue between H and C Street  will be closed the project is set to be  completed by June of next year  well